um i just i saw this uh this documentary
series on netflix called murder mountain
yeah which was like really fascinating
crazy about humboldt county and how like
when it was sort of like the prohibition
era of growing pot all these people
would go missing and it was like
super crazy but the way that that series
played out they almost made it sound
like the the marijuana industry was way
better off before the legal legalization
because now like they they tax everybody
like all this regulation it's like
impossible for these small farmers to
make any money at it
like do you have an opinion about like
the legalization yeah i mean you know
that that was something a lot of people
worried about in when when um
it
first became legal because there was a
lot of stuff that people didn't
understand in the legislation that would
eventually affect um small businesses
independents you know mom and pop type
of right you know companies that were
trying to come up
but nobody saw that you know everybody
you know
the folks that were deeply invested they
just saw legalization and they didn't
give a [ __ ] how it was going to affect
the small guys right but in any business
when you're trying to legalize it you're
going to give regulation and you're
going to get taxes and that is the
bottom line on any business so that's
the sacrifice that that
you know we had to think about as as
people in the industry that like okay if
we're gonna make this legit and make it
legal
we have to scale up we got to scale up
and and we got to abide by this now it's
it's it's hard to adapt when
you know obviously now you got all these
regulations you got to have these
licenses and permits and all this and
that costs money right you know that
affects your bottom line and then now
you got to produce on top of
you know that you got to make up for
what you just invested in there because
if you don't got the capital
it's [ __ ] tough to to exist in that
way and and i think the people that put
the legislation together they knew that
you know and and it's it's
a lot of us that said it that that when
it came you know those of us that had a
strong brand and a strong name
in the in the industry
we wouldn't be
affected the same way right and you know
in some places i got [ __ ] on because i
was talking about you know what we
should
wait
to legalize this [ __ ] here because the
legislation
ain't in the favor of of the small
business
owner you know it's going to wash you
guys out there's going to be this big
ass wave whoever survives the wave
is going to do great business and
they'll be a strong brand
and they'll be able to survive in what's
coming when the corporate money comes in
those of us that don't survive we're
just going to
wash away we're going to have to sell
our licenses
and [ __ ] like this right and that's
exactly what the [ __ ] happened so i i
could understand why
some of those folks up there want to
just unplug and not be a part of
of the [ __ ] but if you're trying to be a
legal brand
or a legal retailer
you know
it is what it is right now you know it
costs to make it cost to be in this
business but once you get it going and
once you get your momentum and
you know like cookies is a great example
i mean you know they started with one
store
and a huge hype on their name and
the expansion that they've had has been
incredible yeah you know and we're
pretty much right behind him in that in
in terms of our expansion we're about to
you know push to to open
many stores outside of california now
here in california we got six
so
you know
um
it's all about trying to get your brand
right
and adhering to the [ __ ] rules and
regulations that
and and
and just
operate
the way you need to right now so that
they they don't have an excuse to
take your licenses away or to you know
stomp your [ __ ] brand out because i
mean realistically it's
i think
you know our taxation here in california
is very high which is unfair like
there's no industry that gets taxed the
way the cannabis industry does so is it
like 20 25
higher than that
yeah then california is already the
highest and then with cannabis oh yeah
there
is no
um we get no reprieve
and realistically cannabis sort of
helped california through these times in
the pandemic because a lot of these
shops
were allowed to stay open as essential
businesses because you know for some
people it's medicine you know what i
mean and i would say the cannabis
industry has held california up i mean
it's it's revenue that it didn't have i
mean even the entertainment industry was
leaving california because it was too
expensive to operate here right and do
production here so they go to somewhere
cheaper that's been going on before the
pandemic
yes since way before the pandemic you
know so california needed the revenue
and yet our taxes are so [ __ ] high
you know i think they need to fix that
well i know they need to fix that but
that's that's a part of the [ __ ] it's
unfair to all of us but
imagine that
you know
people that have partners that are let's
just say
um
they they're funded
that they you know they they have funds
to to make it through this wave people
that aren't funded
wiped well and plus too like getting
into the weed business it's like a lot
of these people were on the black market
before and like oh [ __ ] let's get legal
and then they get legal and then they're
like okay cool where's this money coming
from they're like well i can't really
like document where it's coming from
yeah and somebody just don't want to pay
the taxes
right i mean you're making all this
money and you're not paying taxes you
got your overhead and you know what that
is most of these guys know what their
[ __ ] is and they know what they got to
do to make x amount
but it feels good taking it all in
and not having to give nobody nothing
but that's not the way it's like great
how are you going to fund this well i
can dump like 500 000 and okay cool can
you document where that came from
yeah
because that's the other thing yeah and
at that money ain't even taking your
banks
you know till it's federally legal
across the board
banks aren't really going to take your
cannabis money
indian reservations will though yeah
yeah they will but that's risky yeah you
know what i mean that that's risky any
any of that is is definitely risky but i
mean you got to do something
and so you know you open up a laundromat
next door and watch the money
it's called stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and if you go on amazon and
type in stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and order yourself a bottle
you'd be really helping me because right
now we're ranked number 30 on all of
amazon and if you buy a bottle we might
go up the ladder and that would mean a
lot so please get on amazon and buy
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude